hello everyone and welcome to yet
another excellent game from round three
of the Greinke just classic 2019 as
usual you can always check up some of
the links in the description below you
can always check up the impressions from
the previous round and some of the
introduced after the game from the
players if they will be available they
will also be available in the
description below so always keep that in
mind now getting into this game we do
have some nice footage from it so let's
just check it out
it's a three very short clips Vincent
Kaymer versus Fabiana Caruana let's
check them out there's young Vince
looking sharp as always then we have
this very nice clip again of Vincent
there's some blurry karana
on the left and also we have this very
nice footage of Khurana making a move
doesn't matter what the position is as
you will not see anything but there we
have it just to get into the mood and
now let's check it out so Vincent has
the white pieces and he opens with d4 so
on day one Vincent played against world
champion Magnus Carlsen for seven hours
he almost did something there but in the
end he lost then he faced former world
champion which MANET an island in round
two and now he faces last year's World
Chess Championship challenger Fabiano
Caruana if you want to torture a
fourteen-year-old this is how you do it
and Khurana replies with Knight to f6 we
have c4 e6 and now Knight to f3 and
Bishop to b4 with check vincent blocks
Bishop to D 2 and now Queen to e7
defending the bishop on before g3
vincent prepares to be in Cairo the
delights were Bishop Knight to c6 and
now a3 asking Khurana do you want to go
back or do we want to capture on d2
capturing is the main line so this is
what Caruana does
Queen captures in the now d5 by Vincent
sorry Michael wanna rush up to g2 both
players Castle and here there are three
games available in the database above
all three now continue with the D
captures on c4 but b6 is a new move this
is what Cara wanna plays and well it's
as of this moment that we have a
completely new game on our hands
Queen to c2 defending the c4 pawn also
nightly for if it comes it will not come
with an attack on the Queen and also the
threat is just C captures on d5 that
will open an attack from the Queen to
the night but Corona prevents everything
by playing Bishop to b7 see captors on
d5 ECAP person b5 and now Knight to c3
Vincent continues developing pieces and
here Knight to d8 Corona now wants to
push c5 he wants the riemann over the
night III by Vincent c5 is now being
played attacking the center with a nice
C pawn and rook F the d1 just developing
the rook Knights to e6 by Caruana
and now rook a to c1 and with the small
Vincent finishes development Carolina
still has to decide what to do with da
and DF Rock so rook F to d8 developing
at the counter to rockin the D file and
now Queen to be won by Vincent rook 8
the c8 karana now also finishes
development and here b4 forces Carolina
to make a choice do we want to capture
or do we want to push c4 and block the
center karana decides to push c4 and
here we have Knight to e5 now this is an
excellent night and for the moment black
doesn't really have anything to kick it
away as he only has a light square
bishop and the Knights well he can kick
it away by playing something like this
but it's not time for that just yet
karana goes for g6 and here he gives
Vincent a target so Vincent immediately
decides to go for h4 we have h4 by
Vincent and now Knight to f8 the night
will be a nice defending piece there but
also he's preparing Knights the d7 to
finally trade off this very strong night
Vincent has in the center we have Queen
to be 2 as Vincent is preparing to push
both f4 and g4 and well if if an attack
does happen the Queen from b2 will be
more likely to join the attack through
the second rank with night 8 the d7 now
preparing to capture on e5 and Vincent
pushes f4 and now cementing death knight
on e5 and if Khurana wants to capture it
then well Vincent will have a semi-open
f5 to use for his rooks
we have a six by khurana preparing b5
and now comes the bishop to h3 now
putting pressure on the rock and c8 and
here
b5 and Vincent goes for g4 he's not
afraid and he's a well his teacher Peter
Aleppo was very impressed by the g4 move
he said that that's how he played chess
not being afraid of Caruana
I just you know go forward the the
queenside is blocked at the center is
blocked you're the one controlling the
game and you're the one who decides when
a breakthrough happens on the Kings side
and here you have to be careful if you
play something like King to g7 then you
will face something like g5 and after
this Knight moves it will just be a very
unpleasant position for black and you
can see now that the Queen can join the
attack Queen to h2 hence a queen to be
too idea h5 is coming opening up the H
file and then the Queen will be very
strong along the H file
so after g4 Khurana decides to get rid
of the knight on e5 Knight captures on
e5 with F captures on e5 forcing Caruana
to move the to move the knight and now
Vincent can look I can use the DF file
for his rooks Knights the e4 Knight
captures D captures and now g5 really
controlling the f6 square of course I'm
innocent will now bring his rook over
the rook to F 1 2 F 6 is coming and s
Khurana doesn't have any Knights he only
has a light square bishop which isn't
doing all that much for a moment be it
will be very hard to dislodge anything
from the f6 square and you can imagine
that if something like this happens pawn
captures on f6 then the Queen can easily
come to h6 well not through there
obviously but something like this and
well threaten checkmate for the rest of
the game it will be very hard for corner
one or two to do anything first look to
c7 to well to lessen any threats along
the F file as corona knows that wins and
will double up on the F file so rook to
f1 even is ready
Bishop to d5 now Bishop now also guards
the f7 pawn and now just look to f6 as
planned we have looked the seat
sorry not that rook rook to c6 hoping
that Vincent will capture here but
Vincent just improves his pressure along
the air file we
Queen to f2 and the now a5 Khurana now
has to look for chances on the Queen
side he wants to capture on b4 and well
use the a file for his rook with h5 by
Vincent here everyone was saying
Covington displaying both on the Queen
set end of the King side he's preparing
to push h6 maybe create some sort of a
and alpha 0 position but ok a capture
Sun before a cap for some before and
here rope to a faith and here Vincent
was very happy when Corona played rook
to f8 and he immediately played rook to
f1 but this has already moved 32 and
they still have eight moves to make to
reach time control and it's a it's a
very delicate position here a Vincent
played rook to f1 he decided he
immediately wants to deliver checkmate
in in in any way he can but as a six was
the threat a rook to f8 was a very nice
move by Caruana but there was a deadlier
move instead of rook to see one if you
want well it's it's hard to decide what
to play here for example if you play a
row captures this is not possible
because the white will not capture the
require a black will capture on g5 would
check and then after you block only then
will black capture and no longer you'd
have any sort of an attack black is just
better here so there is one move you can
play here that's better than Vincent's
idea I have to look to a fate but it's a
really really insane engine line so I'll
give you a couple of seconds if you want
to try and find it but it's it's just
really crazy in case any of you found it
really congratulations you you're just a
mastermind and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show there is the
fancy line of Queen to f4 controlling
the g5 phone and now you will be able to
capture here and the Queen will be
guarding the g5 pawn but there is this
idea of Queen captures on b4 and now
here's the problem
you play Bishop to d7 now you force
black to capture on f6 after black
characters you now play G captures on f6
good ideas of Queen to h6 followed by
Queen to g7 checkmate once the rook
moves now not of course Queen to h6
because Queen to f8 can block checkmate
first you play pawn captures on g6
this is the point and only after H
captors on g6 now you play bush back to
g4 I do not allow the rook to capture a
bishop and also the bishop is
controlling some of the squares here
around the White King if if black
decides to play some tricky jerking
ideas but here now after black makes
some move let's say rook to e8 now you
go for east six and here white will
break through bunch of characters you
can go Bishop captures F captures and
now Queen to h6
threatening checkmate and after Queen to
f8 now all sorts of ideas are possible
Queen captures on g6 check King h8 Queen
to h5 check King g8 now comes rook to f1
preparing f7 and only after the Queen
blocks now you go
Queen to h6 preparing a nice roof lifts
and only after our Queen trade is
offered as there there's no way to block
this
now you go f7 check and now it's over
but you know it's it's really a crazy
line and you can't really calculate it
you have to really hot you have to wing
it and see what happens
but that's obviously not how you play
against World Chess Championship
challenger so here at Vincent decided to
go for rook to f1 and now comes the move
Vincent missed because if he saw the
move he most likely would have gone for
that idea even though it's impossible to
calculate it all the way until the end
here c3 and now you can see the problems
c2 and c1 is coming and also you can see
that the bishop is now free to control
the a2 square and now you can see this
rook a h-2a to idea and now it's not all
that easy to decide what to do here
still Queen to f4 was a Vincent's best
choice but Vincent went King to h2 now
making it even even more possible for
Corona to immediately activate the rook
here Corona played rook to e8 because
now the Queen and King are aligned now
rook to a2 is a terrible threat the
bishop still controls the a2 square and
there's no good way to handle this I
mean there is here a Vincent played H
captures on g6
but still kink the g3 would have
promised an interesting game because now
after Luke - 8 - you can go still Queen
to f4 and now
if black decides to pull the pawn let's
say want to see - now you can still play
east six and well it will just be a
winning game for white but this is not
forced this is just something that is
possible after the King moves from from
the second rank now if you bring the
Queen into the game black does have two
queens but it doesn't mean all that much
if you capture here you attack the black
queen but now let's say black threatens
checkmate you can just go rocky faith
checking here in h6 checkmate one of the
possibilities but you have to get to the
king away from the second ring here at
Vincent played a chapter son g 6h
captures on g6 and now he captured the
rook captures on c6 now the king is no
longer here so the Queen cannot capture
the g5 pawn with check Bishop captures
on c6 and now rook to c1 it's smooth 36
events and still has to make four moves
to reach time control and he's down to
about I think about 2 minutes at about
this point so he attacks the seats
respond but karana now just captures the
be fun now he will move the Queen and he
will start pushing the beep on as well
and it seems that there is no the
attacking Vincent had no longer exists
now Vincent plays King to g3 but now it
is it is somewhat 2 to 8 Queen to a3
attacks the rook we have looked 8:1 and
here just see - and you can't capture it
if you capture then just Queen captures
here King h2o Queen a for chair King
moves and now III comes with to check
and well it's a winning position for
black so after c2 ivanson said ok no
more waiting now we have to go all-in he
played a six so what do you do here
obviously if you capture then you get
Bishop captures with the check King g7
and Queen to f6 checkmate this is not
possible for Caruana
but there is a move that's possible and
that's either to bring the rook back or
to just block it with Bishop - eh now
the f7 pawn is protected there are no
tricks here Queen to d2 was played but
now just Queen to d3
Caruana offers a trade of Queens and
there's not all that much you can do
here Queen to f2 was played by Vincent
and now rook to a3 as there are no
threats from White's perspective Caruana
threatens to win the e3 pawn and then
blacks position will
further deteriorate King to f4 was
played defending these three pawns and
here coronal just played King Queen to
d1 and it was in this position that
Vincent Kaymer resigned the game
what if you resign well there's nothing
to do here let's say there really isn't
anything you can do here you have to
protect your rope here if you capture
then just pawn captures you you lose the
loop for nothing if you don't do it
black will just bring another Queen into
the game and there's no there's no good
move white can make but I did I did
think of a funny idea that tell Vincent
could have tried but it's I think it
would be rude to try something like this
against someone of kuranes caliber I
thought of the idea of pawn captures an
f7 Bishop captures and now Bishop here
and now if Carolina would be gullible
enough you know to just bring the Queen
into the game and I have this trick of
Bishop captures with check you can still
avoid this trick by going King g7 but if
you capture now you get King captures
here with check and now you can't go
anywhere towards the center or you're
getting made it so you have to go back
King g8 and now you have this rook to H
a teacher captures and now you can have
a nice perpetual here but that's a lot
of maybes and of course Kerwin I would
not fall for this with you no never but
you know I don't know so some some
sneaky players would would try even
something like this because you know
history is full of sneaky sneaky plays
like this and it does happen our buddy
Vincent is too respectful towards
Caruana to even attempt such a such a
silly idea yeah that's the game camera
versus Caruana from round three of the
Greinke chess classic 2019 as always
there there will be a couple of useful
links in the description below so do
check it out and yeah I would like to
thank Pierre Alexandre Welles
lemo Moreau Vincente quintanilla Peter
East and Simon Johansen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content so thank you all have an
excellent rest of your day